Ryan Co burger in a Moscow, Idaho,
courtroom.
Only a five minute
drive away from the crime scene.
The maximum penalty for this offense,
if you were to plead guilty
or be found
guilty is death or imprisonment for life.
Do you understand?
Yes. Charged with four counts of murder.
The accused killer with zero
visible emotion on his face
just before his initial court
appearance began.
The unsealing of the probable cause
affidavit with disturbing
and potentially damning information
There was other people home at that time.
We've known two other roommates were in
the house on the morning of the murders.
But it was a mystery
if either of them hurt or saw anything.
Now we know of roommate
with the initials DM.
Told investigators
she was in her room and heard crying.
The affidavit prepared by a Moscow, Idaho,
police corporal
has this disturbing detail
She opened the door for the third time
after she heard the crying
and a figure clad in black clothing
and a mask that covered the person's
mouth and nose walking towards her.
Diem described
the figure as five, ten or taller male,
not very muscular, but athletically built
with bushy eyebrows.
The male walked past him
as she stood in a frozen shock phase.
The male walked towards the back
sliding glass door.
Diem locked herself in a room
after seeing the male
DM did not state
that you recognize the male.
The affidavit says that earlier,
when DM heard crying
from one of the victim's rooms,
she heard a male voice
say something to the effect
of, It's okay, I'm going to help you.
It's not
clear if the intruder ever saw Diem.
Dam's description
helped provide valuable information
when police found a Hyundai Elantra
in an apartment building.
15 minutes across the state
line, in Pullman, Washington.
Yeah, there's the shooting
and everything and learned.
The owner matched that description,
and the affidavit
has this chilling set of details.
The police officer
seen as he entered one of the bedrooms,
I could see
two females in the single bed in the room.
Both Kelley Gonzalez and Madison Morgan
were deceased with visible stab wounds.
I also later noticed what appeared to be
a tan leather knife sheath
laying on the bed next to Madison Morgan's
right side.
The sheath was later
processed and had KBR,
which is the company that makes military
and tactical knives, USMC
and the United States
Marine Corps, Eagle Globe, an anchor
insignia stamped on the outside of it.
The Idaho State Lab later
located a single source of male
DNA left on the button snap of the knife
sheath and according to the affidavit.
Last week, Pennsylvania agents
recovered the trash from the Coburg
or family residence
located in Albright's Ville, Pennsylvania.
DNA from Coburg. His father was retrieved.
Police say the father's DNA proved that
what they found in the murder house
is the son's DNA.
Police have determined the murders
were carried out between four and four.
20 5 a.m..
A review of footage from multiple videos
obtained from the King Road neighborhood
showed multiple sightings of suspect
vehicle one starting at 3:29 a.m.
and ending at 4:20 a.m..
Upon review of the video,
there are only a few cars
that enter and exit this area
during time frame.
While details on the affidavit
are specific.
It's still not clear if police know
of a motivation for the killings
or if the accused murderer
or any of the victims.
But based on the affidavit,
it appears the accused murderer targeted
this house between June
and the date of the murder in November.
The police officer says Coburg.
Her cell phone signal was received
12 times near the house of the victims
over a period of five months
before the stabbings
All of these occasions,
except for one, occurred in the late
evening and early
morning hours of the respective days.
We are there.
These details
only add to the pain of the victim's
family members, some of whom were in court
for this hearing.
It's obviously an emotional time
for the family
seeing the defendant for the first time.
This is the
beginning of the criminal justice system,
and the family will be here for the long
haul.
And Gary Tuchman joins us now
live from Idaho.
I mean, Gary, the details
in that affidavit are really stunning.
And it seems like he
I don't know
if stalking is the right word,
but certainly casing that property
for a long time, late
and late at night in the early morning
hours of the course of several months.
Did anything else
stand out to you in the affidavit?
Yeah, there is a detail, Anderson,
that stands out to me,
and that's this
according to the affidavit,
Police say Coburg, his cell phone
signal was again
detected 5 hours after the stabbings
in the same neighborhood
where the houses basically
the inferences that the alleged killer
went back to the house
after the sun came up Anderson.
That's that's something. Gary
Tuchman, appreciate.
I'm joined now
by Mary Ellen O'Toole, a retired FBI
special agent and legendary profiler.
Also, John Miller, CNN chief
law enforcement and intelligence analyst.
John, some of your reporting.
We want to start with that.
We mentioned in the intro to Gary's report
about what the suspect
was allegedly doing in his family's home
in Pennsylvania involves garbage bags.
What have you learned on that?
So just to give that some context,
Anderson, you've got the Pennsylvania
State Police and FBI surveillance team
in a rural area where it's
very hard to do surveillance because, you
know, strange cars would stand out.
So they're watching the house
from a distance.
And what I'm told
by the law enforcement sources
that Kielburger comes out a number
of times, he cleans the car
extensively, almost as if, you know,
you were going to clean it,
to sell it as a new car
inside, outside every inch of it.
And during much of these trips
in and outside of the house,
the source says he's
wearing surgical gloves.
This is what they're observing
in the surveillance.
The other thing is there's a period
where he comes out at 4:00 in the morning
with two bags of garbage
walks by their own garbage
and puts it in the neighbor's bins.
So when they did the trash cover
to recover his garbage,
they took that as well.
And of course, that is the search
that led to the recovery of DNA,
which then matched to the sheath
and the knife, according to the affidavit.
And it's that familial DNA
that they found, the father's DNA,
they could tell
it was the son, which, as you and I have
talked about, is is can be controversial.
It can be.
And, you know, there's only 12 states
that allow that as that kind of evidence,
but that was to reach probable cause.
The first thing they did
when that SWAT team went through the door
and took him into custody was
they had another search warrant,
which allowed them to take hair and swabs
and collect his DNA from his person,
which is now in the process.
Of being matched in that lab.
So they're going to get
from a highly probable
statistical answer to one
that's going to be fairly certain.
Also, John, we've been waiting for more
than seven weeks
for the details that we learned today.
What do you make of the evidence,
the timeline of the investigation?
So that's really interesting, Anderson,
because people have been talking about
why did this take so long
when actually if you look at the timeline,
you can actually see a process.
Let's walk through it for a second.
November 13th is when you have the murders
and that is the starting point for police.
Ten days later,
they get the DNA confirmation.
November 25th,
they've now looked at the video
and they know they're looking for a white
Hyundai couple.
Berg's car is located
at Washington State University,
and he becomes a part of the focus
because of the car once
they have the cell phone profile on him
that shows he's been in the neighborhood.
And that's December 7th.
He becomes of high interest
by December 23rd.
They see that Coburg cell phone
has been hitting near the crime scene.
And December 28th,
they get that DNA match.
December 29th, they make the arrest.
So what you see is
while police weren't telling us a lot
and they were asking for the public's help
and they were going out to the media
every couple of days with an update.
There was a lot going on behind the scenes
between the Moscow
police, a small department that doesn't
have a lot of experience in homicide.
The Idaho State Police Homicide Team
and the FBI which brought kind of unique
resources in terms of cell phone tracking,
video analysis, profilers and so on.
A lot of work went into this.
Mary Ellen, based on what we learn
of the affidavit, what stands out to you?
Well,
several things stand out
because they come together like a puzzle.
And the first thing is that
we've all been commenting on the fact
that here's a Ph.D.
studying in criminology.
And he left behind
a very significant piece of evidence
from which they were able to extract DNA.
Then you have the information from cameras
and then you have the information
from the cell towers
that that pinged on his phone.
These were mistakes
that are not consistent with somebody
that is smarter than everybody else
and knows more than anybody.
So, you know,
I think it puts it into perspective for me
that just because you're studying
for a Ph.D.
in criminology does not allow you
to commit the perfect crime.
There are forensic and the behavioral
evidence was there and they discovered it.
The the
returning what seems
to be I don't know if it was returning
to the scene or staying in the area,
the cell phone paying the Gary Tuchman
talked about several hours after
the murders were committed.
What what do you make of that?
Well, looking at that in connection
with some of the other things
that have surfaced on this case,
originally, you could look at it
and say what's naivete?
It's lack of experience
and it could be some of that.
But I also think
it's a sense of arrogance.
And I also think it could be
a sense of I'm smarter than the police are
and they're never going to be able
to tie me to the case.
And that will remain to be seen
based on his behavior in the courtroom.
But I do think that arrogance
is really bleeding through in a variety
of the photographs that we've seen
and in the videos that we've seen on him.
So, again, it depends.
It really is going to come down
to his behavior in the courtroom.
Mary Ellen O'Toole,
John Miller, appreciate it. Thank you.